welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and while thor love and thunder's
first trailer does not feature christian
bale's gore the god butcher terrorizing
the gods of the mcu we do see a rather
terrifying sight in the form of these
toothy black creatures that appear to be
terrorizing people in the background
people who very likely would not like to
be eaten by a black beast as that
usually gets the way of achieving one's
hopes and dreams but just what the hell
are these creatures and where the hell
do they come from anyway well let us
speculate on just who these naughty
nibblers of the night just might be my
nerd babies let's do it and of course
you can hit up new rockstarsmerch.com to
buy one of these cool ass tomb of the
moon god latest obsession shirts these
are not gonna last forever so hit up new
rockstars merch today so you can buy it
now and own it forever before it goes
into the new rockstar's vault and um you
know just disappears forever like a
ghost alright so like i was saying
before in the 411 thunder trailer
specifically if you look at the bottom
left corner of the screen while natalie
portman flexes with her new bestie
mjolnir you can see a poor man in a
hoodie getting his left rib freaking
chomped by a scary black creature with
sharp ass teeth but while there isn't an
official word as to who these creatures
might be the first and most logical
guest is the black berserkers because we
all know jane foster's mighty thor is
about to throw some serious hands with
one of marvel's mightiest menaces gore
the godbutcher right and we also know
that god's gift to man taikawatiti is
taking a ton of inspiration from
marvel's 2012's gore god of thunder
comic as evidenced by this incredible
live-action recreation of marvel artists
as said ribbitch's already jaw-dropping
arch and if marvel studios hasn't
already paid this man please pay this
man for his art because you straight up
just copied his art into live action
which is great but please make sure your
artists are taken care of please it's
just nice it's a nice thing to do you
know and we learned from that comic run
that what makes gore so good at getting
gods to give up the ghost is a super
powerful sword known as all black the
necro sword a sword that a previously
mortal gore took off the unconscious
body of a dark primordial god by the
name of null who forged it from the very
darkness before the big bang and that
sword made gore functionally immortal as
long as gore had that sword and one of
the powers that all black the necro
sword has outside of you know gliding
through the guts of gods easier than
your grandma can cut a birthday cake is
the ability for the wielder to summon
black eyeless creatures of darkness from
the very blade itself and gore learned
that he could do this right after he
bonded with his sword physically after a
young thor chops his arm off in the
issue thor 11 thunder number 5 and gore
would frequently use these black
berserkers to assist him during his one
man quest to eliminate all the gods in
the universe and not only are these
beasts some formidable foes for multiple
thor variants in the comics but whenever
a thor did manage to defeat a black
berserker gore would actually feel the
pain of this defeat because he was
symbiotically bonded with the all black
necrosword where all these beasts came
from so this symbiote of a sword is
physically a part of him now however due
to the sheer amount of power that the
all black necrosword provided gore the
godbutcher it really wasn't that big of
a deal if a couple of these mindless
monsters were to perish fighting a god
of thunder or two so it's like ah
whatever i felt that but that's no big
deal so with these creatures in the
trailers not seeming to have any
noticeable eyeballs in their heads at
all it's a safe bet to assume that these
are the mcu's adaptations of the all
black necroswords all black berserking
beasts this video is brought to you by
the ridge the ridge wallet is light
sleek and industrial and it's designed
to fit in your front pocket unlike those
bulky old old school wallets that make
you look like you're smuggling an 80s
car phone in your back pocket it's
ridiculous check this out nice and sleek
there are over 30 colors and styles
including carbon fiber and bird's
titanium and it holds up to 12 cards and
still has room for cash in the back and
every ridge wallet comes with a lifetime
guarantee and that lets you test drive
it for 45 days and send it back for a
full refund if you don't love it which
you will and the wallets have over forty
thousand five star reviews and it's made
with rfid blocking technology that
protects you from digital pickpocketers
and they also have other cool products
like this commuter backpack it's
weatherproof and great for toting around
a laptop and this month marks nine years
since the ridge started and they're
celebrating with a special sale so get
15 off today with free worldwide
shipping and free returns by going to
ridge.com new rockstars that's ridge.com
new rockstars and use the code new
rockstars find the link in this video's
description and we thank ridge again for
sponsoring this video but hold on now
because something isn't exactly right
here because yeah these guys don't seem
to have any eyes but in the marvel
comics the black berserkers are 100
black creatures meaning that like they
didn't even possess white teeth in their
mouths while these beasts in the
trailers appear to have two very
apparent rows of dental death in their
mouths like they're those are very sharp
teeth being used to chomp on this man
which makes me believe that the black
berserkers aren't the only possible
suspect here because as we have already
seen with king the conqueror's
introduction in the loki finale as well
as the inclusion of professor xavier
from the fox x-men films in multiverse
of madness marvel studios is very much
ready and willing to use all the assets
that they acquired from disney's
purchase of 20th century fox including
its rights to one of marvel's most
deadly dark demons of disaster the brood
that's right everybody the brood
entering the marvel comics universe
through a flow of dark matter from a
neighboring dead universe the brood are
the darkest and most ruthless enemies in
the cosmos that reproduce their numbers
by parasitically impregnating human
hosts you know sort of like the
xenomorphs in the alien series however
unlike xenomorph babies in the movies
that would violently burst out of their
human hosts brood babies would actually
slowly change their human host into a
brood over time like physically change
them into a disgusting looking brood
which is just as messed up as it sounds
the brood also possessed long teeth
extremely similar to those of the
mysterious black monsters behind jane
foster and some of the brood also had
tentacles which could help explain those
weird tentacled creatures behind thor
odinson being attacked by this huge mob
of people that don't really care for
this huge tentacled creature in their
neighborhood and you know what i don't
care for that either if i was in that
weird squidward town of all the
squidward people in that episode of
spongebob i would hyperventilate so
considering the dark roots of the all
black necrosword with the mcu primordial
realm i can see this all black
necrosword being able to summon the
brood from the dark void to help gore
the godbutcher raise hell especially
since the brood have been known to be
quite sadistic with their food in the
comics which could also be why the
monster behind jane seems to be nibbling
and playing with his potential food
rather than actually fully biting down
to the poor man and just ending his
misery and considering how the mcu has
started to really lean into the
multiverse side of things having the
interdimensional brood be born from the
very same darkness between universes
that wong sort of alluded to in
spiderman no way home that spell travels
the dark borders between known and
unknown reality it's too dangerous to
help christian bale do some
non-christian impaling just makes sense
to me but what do you guys think let us
know in the comment section below do you
guys think that these could actually be
the brood or do you guys think it's just
the berserkers let us know but anyways
thank you guys so much for watching this
video you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some really weird [ __ ] but
more importantly you can follow new
rockstars wherever we are on social
media and when you do on youtube make
sure you hit that notification bell so
you get notifications every time we
upload a video and of course hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can get this
awesome tomb of the moon god latest
obsession shirt get that now before it's
gone forever because we're always
getting new shirts but anyways thank you
guys so much for watching again i love
you guys so much and i'll see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]
you